Socrates gets up
Socrates says I can't give a speech
you know I thought I was up to it but
then I hear these guys and these are
some real you know talkers I I'm not
that kind of guy
if you want I can do the sort of thing
that I do every day you guys all know me
I like to ask people questions and we
talk about stuff I can do that but I
can't do this this you know
getting a big
workout articulate speech is that okay
with you and they say yeah that's that's
fine so what does he do now remember
whose party is this it's agathons right
agathon just gave the best speech
what do Socrates do
tears it apart
turns out agathon didn't know what he
was talking about